what do we want data and where do we
want it
in buckets in this episode of cloud
storage bytes we take a look at buckets
and why they are the cornerstone of
everything you do
stay tuned for more
before you can do anything in cloud
storage you've got to create a bucket
because anything you want to store in
cloud storage needs a
bucket in order for you to do anything
with it
when configuring your bucket you need to
make three initial decisions
name location and storage class
first a bucket needs a globally unique
name and this can't be changed
so choose a name that will be relevant
and useful to you
we've got great documentation on naming
so we'll go ahead and link that in the
description
once you've named your bucket you need
to select a location
you should choose location based upon
what type of redundancy options you need
where your primary users
are and what your expected first time to
byte is when caching is turned off
generally you should store your data in
a location that's convenient
or contains the majority of the users of
your data
there are three different types of
locations region
dual region and multi region this gives
you plenty of flexibility in choosing
the location that will work best for you
since location can't be changed once
that bucket is created
use a region to help optimize latency
and network bandwidth for data consumers
such as analytics pipelines
that are grouped in the same region use
a dual region when you want similar
performance advantages
as regions but you also want the higher
availability that comes with being
geo-redundant
and use a multi-region when you want to
serve content to data consumers that are
outside of the google network
and distributed across large geographic
areas or when you want the higher
availability that comes with
geo-redundancy
and finally you choose a storage class
which you can update later on but if you
don't select anything initially
this will default to standard let's dive
in and see what that actually means
cloud storage has four different storage
classes
all offer low latency and high
durability but they vary based on their
availability and minimum storage
durations
along with the pricing for storage and
access
data that will be served at a high rate
with high availability should use the
standard storage class
this class provides the best
availability with the trade-off of a
slightly higher price
data that will be infrequently accessed
and can tolerate a slightly lower
availability should be stored using the
near line storage
cold line storage or archive storage
classes
your choices here are going to vary
depending on your specific needs
i like to think about using nearline for
something i'll access
once a month or so and archive for
something i'll need about once a year
and cold line for the stuff in between
the documentation will help you make the
best choice here
now that you know what goes into cloud
storage and where it goes we'll get to
the good stuff
like how to get it there and what to do
with it until then
subscribe give us a like and let us know
what features of cloud storage you'd
like to learn more about
thanks for joining us for this quick
bite of cloud storage
[Music]
you